you answered a question about
complainers and said you would listen to
the because well it should be listened
to them right yes you said you would
listen to them because you can learn
what the problems are I like it and
people like to be heard but how do you
handle chronic complainers the type of
people who become cancerous me to an
extreme others it should take thanks for
you to do this this is the calls once
again for my favorite my favorite
general remedy in in leadership
situations is you take this person and
you put them in charge but I'm in charge
yeah and this is one of those classic
things where someone says hey why are we
even doing it this way and you say oh
echo you don't like that cool why don't
you come up with the plan and you go
execute it and however you want yeah and
and that does one or two things either
they they say okay and they step up and
then they have to figure out how hard
the job the task is and they have to get
it done and it's they learn from it and
they get humbled by it and they
recognize the the the burden of
responsibilities that a leader actually
has which is all good or they just say
no no and they stop complaining because
they don't want to get to have a now
what you gotta be careful with a lot of
these answers that I give you could go
like in the wrong direction so what I
mean by that is echo says hey I don't
like will do the way we're doing this
and I go okay well then you're in charge
you don't I mean I do it like that it's
a punishment it's a unitive thing that
isn't absolutely not what I'm talking
about I say you know what echo you're
pointing out some good stuff you're
pointing out some definite shortfalls in
the way that this is happening I'll tell
you what why don't you actually just
take responsibility for this and you can
run this task and you can make this
happen because I think you know just
based on some of the things you've
pointed out already I'm not even calling
them complaints based on some of the
things you pointed out already I think
you could probably improve upon our
process quite a bit mm-hmm you know so
you gotta be careful I'm not talking
about being a jerk to someone yeah I'm
talking about action and this is the
thing it's like it's like there's
there's there's this thing what I'm
doing I'm not just playing the game you
ever you ever ever
listen jujitsu I'm like hey if you want
to set me up with the choke so that you
can get my arm you have to actually do
the choke you have to actually apply the
pressure if you don't apply the pressure
I'm not defending it and my arms not
gonna go where you want it you have to
actually do it and if I don't defend it
the way you expect me to then you just
choke me yeah it's the same thing here
I'm not saying you just say well why
don't you do it then no you have to
actually say hey listen I think this is
what's going on I think you have some
good points why don't you take lead on
this and we'll see if you can you know
remedy the situation because I think you
got a pretty good chance of doing it
yeah this isn't I'm not doing this as a
punitive thing I'm doing it cuz it's the
best thing for the team you've got a
legitimate complaint you've got a bunch
of them yeah let's get you in a position
where you can store some of those things
out so yeah so that's that's that when
you get people that are complaining you
know first of all hear them out and
maybe that's good enough right
hey listen to him and and and and once
again I'm not saying you listen to him
while your brain is elsewhere and you're
not thinking or you actually listen to
what they're saying you're engaged you
really do go for the choke go for it
listen to what they're saying maybe
there's some solutions you can come up
with but then if that doesn't work and
even after they even after you listen to
them and you explain to them why things
aren't the way they want they still want
to complain it complain about it cool
that's fine awesome why don't you take
lead on this and that way you can sort
out some of these issues appreciate it
kind of like lips it down one time it's
kind of hard to complain about a plan
when it's your plan yeah that is the
truth yeah
make sense god I'm so stupid yeah this
plan sucks that I came up with but the
yeah the chronic complaining because you
could kind of I mean people will
complain a lot you you you it's easy to
be like oh they're chronic complainers
right but if there's constantly we'll
say chronic problems that might induce
chronic complaining I'm not saying
that's the case obviously because I know
there is such thing as chronic
complainers 100% but at the very least
like I you say oh yeah put them in
charge of something or or listen to them
and they'll point you know listen to
what they're complaining about or
whatever you might actually get turned
on to all
solvable problems you know and if you do
if look if you make someone take lead in
in a situation right and you know how
it's kind of like that's got that
concept of like taking extreme ownership
and then what if they do like say yeah
it is your fault and then you get all
mad you know kind of thing it's like oh
so you didn't really do that it's like
so if you put someone else in charge or
something you're really putting them in
charge yeah like what if they run what
if they take lead and they solve all the
problems and it's awesome right yeah
exactly right so you don't treat this
action or this discourse as like
something to get back at the unplaned
it's not just a setup yeah it's a real
move real deal yeah and you know that's
you just you just made this point that I
made which is one of the best leadership
tools that is completely overlooked by
people all the time is very very simple
to do and that's just to listen to what
people are saying I know it sounds crazy
but I've run into all the time leaders
in all kinds of levels all kinds of
situations and the biggest problem they
have is they don't even listen to anyone
else
they won't listen yeah so when you're in
a leadership position try this be quiet
and listen to what people are saying
listen to what they're complaining about
listen to what suggestions they have
listened to what advice they give listen
to their recommendations listen just
listen sometimes you're gonna be in a
much better spot yeah and even like you
saying that out loud sounds real obvious
you know but it's man it's not cuz even
a lot of times like if you don't listen
and think of myself like all the many
trillions trillions of times that I
haven't listened when I should've most
days most of the time will say I don't
mean to not listen I don't mean to be
like it's not like I'm like hearing
noise and being like oh you don't know
what you're talking about you're dumb
you know what you say doesn't mean
anything it's not that it's more that
I'm like focus so hard and what I'm
thinking or my way or whatever like I'm
just so just of course naturally its
mind I've been thinking about it for
years now you know kind of things I'm so
basically dug in to myself on my own
thing that I'm not and I'm just not
paying attention that much you know I'm
like working so hard and down this
Tunnel that like I can't look out of the
tunnel kind of thing so you don't really
mean to but when you're in the situation
it's like it's not that easy you know
it's it's and you know what it is also
it's detachment yeah right because when
you're talking you're talking yeah step
back detach listen to what people are
saying I do this all the time
and do this all the time it's such a
it's such an easy move yeah if you let
me move you just watch you just listen
even like in jujitsu you do this you're
like well the person wants to move
around a bunch come on let him move
around
let's see where they're going I'm just
gonna listen to their moves you know
yeah and that's a good way to put it man
just listen to their moves just listen
and yeah if is if you primarily focus on
that listening then like you habitually
be able to do it way better because like
again like back to the it's not like a
you're not doing it with malicious
intent you know you're not shutting them
down it's almost like you every like
interrupters right you know chronic
interrupter absolutely interrupt me all
the time some of the time a lot of them
whatever we'll say half of the time
estimate there it doesn't feel like
they're doing it because they don't want
to hear what you have to say sometimes
it's that for sure but sometimes they
it's almost like it's almost like they
have this tone of like dang I don't
think I finished my point as good as I
want to do all most of them for
themselves because they're so committed
to their message and what they've been
thinking the whole time
and if you're not signing right on to it
it's a man I must not have said it clear
enough you see them saying I had to like
tighten up my kids on just straight they
just wouldn't let each other talk it
just interrupt interrupt interrupt and I
think it was yeah it was my son for sure
and he looked at me and he goes he's
like he says dad you mean teachers to be
aggressive our whole lives and now all
of a sudden you're telling us just a sip
did you tell him that that's the day
economy I said that's the economy I know